- Do I have a drink right now?
I'm only allowed one with
my antibiotics I'm on.
I'm about to film this
stand-up for my show.
This isn't like a polished set
like I would want to
do for my special,
but I'm proud of where it is.
And hopefully these people
will like hearing about semen.
We're filming the
stand-up tonight.
Do you want to hear
some of my jokes?
Well give me $10,000.
Do you think Jim
Norton or Attell
are having two
fittings in one day?
Making sure that, like,
their ass looks okay
so they can tell a fucking joke.
I can only be as pretty
as I can fucking be.
Look at this, this is
what I'm working with.
Like, I know what I look like.
Like, you'd bang me but
you wouldn't blog about it.
I get it.
(audience laughs)
I wish that everybody
knew how important
this stand-up portion
was to the show.
This is why I have a TV show.
So we're headed to West Nyack
to perform at Levity Live.
I've just been
going on the road,
getting ready for the stand-up
that's gonna be on the show.
Nothing makes you as strong
as going on the road.
We tried to have sex.
It did not happen at all.
My heart was in it.
This lady was not.
(audience laughs)
- Tonight, the culmination
of Amy workshopping material
and working at the clubs.
- And he went, like,
right down on me,
because he was raised well.
(audience laughs)
- She can say filthy,
obscene things
but in the sweetest manner.
- I just think you should
consider, you know,
terminating the pregnancy
if it was rape or incest
or with a redhead.
Like, the
unforgivables, you know?
(audience laughs)
The unacceptables.
When I'm done with my set,
and the last thing that
I'll talk about is,
like, if I were to
have a gaping pussy
from having sex with a guy
with too big of a penis,
and then my NuvaRing would
fall out, and that like,
I'd be looking for it
on the subway platform
and a rat would run by
wearing it like a crown.
And then I'll take questions.
- [Curtis] Okay.
(raucous laughter)
- Oh man, this is
kinda disappointing.
This question is, "How many
fingers am I holding up?"
But I just read, like,
how many fingers,
and I was like, "I've
got this, I've got this!"
(audience laughs)
- It's just been
absolutely incredible
how much new material she's
been able to generate in
A) a short amount of time,
and B) probably one of the
busiest periods of her life.
- [Man] Alright, man,
y'all ready for this
show, man, to start?
Come on, damn it!
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, this hits the spot.
Thank you so much,
I'll see you very soon.
- [Man] Please put your hands
together for Miss Amy Schumer.
(audience cheers)
- Aw, you guys, thank you
so much for coming out.
This is a big deal for me.
- [Man In Crowd] Amy!
- Thank you, but are
you too hot to clap?
(intense rock music)
Like, who's the biggest
slut of you guys?
Like which one?
Oh, they right
away point to her!
They're like boom!
Boom!
(audience laughs)
Good for you.
What's your name?
Dana, yes it is.
She's like Dana, huh?
Are these tickets to this?
(audience laughs)
Oh, cool.
He goes, "Yeah!"
General admission, it's
like embarrassing to see
a ticket for yourself that
says zero point zero zero zero.
(audience laughs)
It's emotional.
This is the show of
my dreams to make,
and I feel really lucky
that I got to make it.
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
Mountain.
They almost called that
show Martin, Mountain,
and then at the last second.
See, if you watch the webseries,
this is the kind of
riffing you're gonna get.